I'm Shannon bream I'm Tom shallou I'm
Maria Bartiromo and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday December 14 2022 a
founder of a now bankrupt cryptocurrency
exchange has already defended himself
publicly but Federal prosecutors aren't
buying what he's selling you don't get
to rob the bank and then say well I'm
not guilty because I intended to return
the money as soon as I was in better
Financial shape you know that's not a
defense I'm Dave Anthony
he's the American in prison in Russia
you may not have heard about
Mark Fogle his case is similar to
Brittany greiner's but like Paul Whelan
he was not set free he's afraid of dying
there
my mother's afraid he's gonna die there
we're all afraid of that and I'm Paul
batura I've got the final word on the
Fox News Rundown
[Music]
once nicknamed the king of crypto Sam
bankman freed is now holding Court in
the Bahamas Department of Corrections
under indictment in the United States
accused of scheming to defraud investors
in the now bankrupt cryptocurrency
exchange he founded FTX he prayed on his
customers the victims of this case
abusing the trust placed not only in his
company but in himself as the lead of
that company Michael Driscoll is the
assistant director in charge of the FBI
in New York where U.S attorney Damian
Williams detailed an eight-count
indictment yesterday calling it one of
the biggest Financial frauds in American
history we charge that from 2019 until
earlier this year bankman freed and his
co-conspirator stole billions of dollars
from FTX customers
he used that money for his personal
benefit including to make personal
Investments and to cover expenses and
debts of his hedge fund Alameda research
in a separate civil complaint the
Securities and Exchange Commission also
accuses bankman freed of diverting funds
without telling customers then using
Alameda as a personal piggy bank
describing it all as a house of cards
built on a foundation of deception the
new court-appointed CEO of FTX John Ray
was more blunt at a house hearing this
is just plain old embezzlement Rey
telling lawmakers the FTX collapse
appears to stem from absolute
concentration of control in the hands of
a small group of people he calls grossly
inexperienced and unsophisticated I've
just never seen an utter lack of
record-keeping uh absolutely no internal
controls whatsoever bankman freed was
also due to appear virtually at that
hearing and was reportedly planning to
tell lawmakers in so many words what he
said in recent interviews that he messed
up up but had never tried to commit
fraud but bankman Freed's testimony was
preempted by his arrest Monday in the
Bahamas a Magistrate Judge denying bail
at his first court appearance there
yesterday while a lawyer for bankman
freed says they're exploring all legal
options anytime you're dealing with
financial fraud in the federal context
and the numbers get to be 7 8 9 10
digits long that's very very serious
Andy McCarthy is a former assistant U.S
attorney for the southern district of
New York and a Fox News contributor and
when they add money laundering charges
that kind of Turbo inflates the
potential prison exposure so they're
extraordinarily serious for a 30 year
old guy we're talking about you know
someone who conceivably could spend the
rest of his life in jail now begman
freed has essentially said during
interviews he didn't intend to commit
any fraud if that's true how much could
that help him well he can't be guilty
unless he intended to commit fraud so a
jury would have to find at a certain you
know whenever the trial takes place that
the government has proved Beyond a
reasonable doubt that he intended it if
he didn't intend it that's a complete
defense to the charges but how do you
prove lack of intent though or is it
more to do with convincing a jury there
is reasonable doubt well you know every
case is different in this case I think
the way prosecutors would go about it
would be simply to say here are the
normal controls that are put in place to
make sure that client money doesn't get
diverted to the purposes of the person
who on Whose representations it was uh
derived there's evidently been a
departure from very basic compliance and
bookkeeping standard and then what I
imagine they would show is two things
one is laid out in the indictment there
are a number of uh bookkeeping tweaks
that were done over time to conceal the
fact that money was being diverted from
FTX to Alameda his other vehicle that he
is said to have diverted everything to
so it's clear that they had a
Consciousness that that was a problem uh
and then there were other tweaks that
were made over time as Alameda became
more and more in Hawk to FTX and
therefore more and more of a big problem
uh for ftx's internal accounting they
took additional steps to conceal that
fact so it's very difficult if they were
able to prove what they've alleged and
you know typically you wouldn't put that
in an indictment unless you were
confident you could prove it it'd be
very difficult to convince people that
he didn't know or intend what happened
now people typically say Bernie Madoff
said this you know that he didn't intend
to defraud people and what he meant by
that
was that it was always his intention to
make people whole in the end that is
like he didn't intend to orchestrate a
catastrophe but of course that's not the
test the test is did you take other
people's money for improper purposes
converted to your own use even if you
intended at some point to make them
whole the crude analogy is kind of a
bank robbery you know you don't get to
rob the bank and then say well I'm not
guilty because I intended to return the
money as soon as I was in better
Financial shape you know that's not a
defense
the hedge fund Alameda in a case like
this is that typically treated as a
separate case would we expect to see you
know more charges and more current or
former officials in trouble over that
the co-mingling of funds and the way
funds were diverted and the way
investors funds were used by Alameda or
is it considered part of all you know
the same case yeah I think it's all
interrelated and in fact Lisa if you
look at the um some of the news we got
this afternoon was that in addition to
the indictment and the complaint that
was filed by the SEC there's also been a
civil complaint filed by the commodity
Futures Trading Commission in which I
believe Alameda is named as a defendant
along with ftxn bankman freed and I
would expect two things here with
respect to the indictment one you know
let's remember that we're in an early
stage and they've obviously got a
charging instrument from the Bohemian
authorities in order to try to get him
extradited we shouldn't assume that the
justice department is at the end of its
investigation it's probably closer to
the beginning and I'd be very surprised
if we didn't at some point see
superseding indictments maybe more than
one in order to flush out the charges
and probably add additional charges and
then the other thing I would point out
to people is there were at least three
conspiracy counts in the indictment that
the justice department filed in which
bankman freed is The Only Name defendant
and I underscore that because under any
it's black letter law you can't conspire
by yourself you know as they say in the
criminal law because it takes two to
tango so if there's not a meeting of the
minds between two people on a criminal
end then there's no conspiracy and what
that necessarily means is the justice
department if they indicted him for
concern literacy they have to think
other people are also guilty of it so I
would expect that you're either going to
see charges against other individuals in
future indictments or it's entirely
possible that other people who are
involved in this are already cooperating
with the justice department and maybe
we'll see guilty pleas down the road
millions of dollars in political
donations are also wrapped up in this
case some lawmakers have questioned the
timing of bankman Freed's arrest on
Monday which was on the Eve of his
scheduled testimony virtually appearing
before a house committee the federal
prosecutor in New York said really the
timing of the arrest was more about law
enforcement and not anything else
related to it but what do you make of
the timing of the arrest
so what I suspect happened here is there
has to be political concerns and it's
highly likely that there are and the
reason I say that is uh the the millions
in campaign contributions that you just
mentioned it's highly likely that if
this hearing can happen today there
would have been a lot of spotlighting of
the fact that bankman freed has been
identified publicly as the number two
contributor to Democrats second only to
George Soros and has reportedly given
about 40 million dollars in this last
cycle so we're talking about a scheme
where what actually is alleged to have
happened here is Bank been freed stole
that money from investors and converted
it to his own use and in part used it to
make campaign contributions so you'd
have this situation where the p people
whose money was stolen from them have
very little Prospect of getting it back
and in the meantime millions of dollars
have gone into the coffers of
politicians so I imagine that would have
been very uncomfortable testimony to sit
through I should underscore though that
you know backmanfried says that he was
an equal opportunity Giver that uh he
gave money to Republicans too he claims
that he gave just about as much money to
both sides so we'll have to see how that
all plays out
is bankman freed better off not going to
trial in a case like this do cases with
this many charges from multiple entities
in this case prosecutors and Regulators
do they make deals in a situation like
this
defendants who are guilty generally
speaking are far better off pleading
guilty than going to trial because the
sentencing guidelines build in some
breaks for people who admit their guilt
and accept responsibility for their
wrongdoing and it's something that
impresses both the justice department
and the court for whom you're hoping to
get leniency obviously people who aren't
guilty uh going to trial is a much
different scenario because that's the
way that you can clear yourself and show
the weaknesses in the government's case
but when a case is overwhelming and we
don't know at this early stage if that's
going to be this case but it certainly
sounds that way because in these
financial fraud cases what you often get
are lots of testimony from insiders and
Witnesses who have a motive to testify
especially if they're casting the blame
on somebody else rather than on
themselves and then there's just
truckloads of documents that are
generally available to corroborate
details of the fraud and if that comes
together in this case like it comes
together in a typical fraud case and
this does look like a very typical fraud
case then the case becomes overwhelming
and to my mind you're much better off
pleading guilty when you're clearly
guilty than rolling the dice and going
to trial because if you get convicted at
trial and you know you flip the
government through all of its phases and
put the court through a trial there's
not much leniency on the other end of
that
how does any of this affect the FTX
bankruptcy case does it make it easier
or more difficult for investors to get
any money back
well whether they can get money back or
not will be a function number one of how
much money there is you know how much is
available to be clawed back uh and then
you know obviously the testimony is very
important in terms of what the
provenance of the funds in FTX was and
you know who knew what about what their
business practices were how badly people
were defrauded one of the big issues for
example in the Bernie Madoff case which
was kind of a classic Ponzi scheme was
whether the people who were at the top
of the scheme were you know there were
accusations that some people who were
involved in that were virtually
co-conspirators because what happens
typically in a Ponzi type scheme is the
people who get in early get their money
back and make money whereas the people
at the end are left holding the bag this
kind of scheme actually looks more at
the moment like one where there's not
much money left and that a lot of you
know we're talking about 32 billion
dollars that disappeared but one of the
things you have to ask is how real was
that in the first place like was it
really ever really worth anything close
to 32 billion dollars so we're a long
way at this stage from figuring that all
out
McCarthy former assistant U.S attorney
for the southern district of New York
and Fox News contributor thank you so
much for your time
my pleasure
[Music]
Paul patero with your Fox News
commentary coming up
Brittany Greiner is upbeat thankful and
hopeful that's what the basketball
star's agent says as she goes through a
reintegration program at an Army
hospital in Texas days after Griner was
set free in Russia this is a day we've
worked toward for a long time President
Biden announced griner's release from
the White House after months of being
unjustly detained in Russia held under
intolerable circumstances Greiner was
detained on drug charges in February for
having cannabis Vape cartridges in her
luggage convicted and sentenced to nine
years in prison then swapped in a
prisoner exchange for convicted Russian
arms dealer Victor boot but Paul Whelan
was not freed with her an American
detained since 2018 as an accused spy
this was not a choice of which American
to bring home we brought home Trevor
Reed when we had a chance early this
year
sadly for totally illegitimate reasons
Russia is treating Paul's case
differently than Britney's and while we
have not yet succeeded in securing
Paul's release we are not giving up the
president faced strong criticism from
Republicans like Congressman Mark Greene
who told Fox it's a terrible message to
send not only to the despots of the
world who now know that they can get a
trade if they just capture an American
but to the military the United States
military who are saying yeah I can serve
this country and the president will
leave me and take the the basketball
player but left out of this entire
discussion is Mark Fogle an American
teacher who's also in prison in Russia
arrested in August 2021 for possessing
like Brittany Greiner Vape cartridges
with hash oil and medical marijuana
given a 14-year prison sentence for
those drugs
unlike Griner and Paul Whelan the U.S
government has never formally declared
Fogle wrongfully detained I was
disappointed the park wasn't on the
plane there's a there's a lot of
conflicting emotion and Fogle is Mark's
sister I'm happy that Brittany greiner's
home
I'm very sad that Mark was not on that
plane
there were members of Congress from
Pennsylvania last week after the release
of Griner who were on your side calling
for your brother's release that he be a
priority for the U.S government to try
to also set free have those members uh
guy rushenthaler and Mike Kelly have
what have they told you
that they're they're essentially running
into a wall there was a resolution to uh
for information from the state
department that did not pass
um they're they're they're running into
the same information block that we are
what is the reason in that you're told
by the state department or the U.S
government that her case was wrongful
detainment but his is not the state
department has been a black box
I've had people at the state department
say thanks to people like your brother
diplomatic families are able to go
overseas together we appreciate the work
that your brother has done all of these
years it allows us to do our work I mean
they uh it's crazy uh the former
ambassador's son was a student of my
brothers you know my brother is not
um he is not an average person he's not
an average teacher he is an
extraordinary teacher he has he's
probably trained the whole next
generation of diplomats
so I don't understand the disconnect
that there's a disconnect of he's so
well revered within the state department
why would they not consider him
wrongfully detained what do they say
when you ask that they will not give an
answer I can't explain the level of
frustration that our family's feeling
so he's been in Russia for nearly a
decade correct well he has been there
for a decade Mark is a history teacher
has been a history teacher for 35 36
years now almost exclusively in the
international school system so he has
taught in Malaysia in Colombia and
Venezuela and uh Oman Mexico he's he's
taught all over the world this was their
final stint they wanted to be in a
European country and Russia filled the
bill
um the pay was good the city was amazing
they enjoyed
um nine phenomenal years there their
kids matriculated through the
anglo-american school there he was
returning to Moscow to finish their 10th
and final retirement year
and while he was returning he goes
through customs at an airport
there's medical marijuana in his luggage
correct correct
17 grams of medical marijuana
and there had been a a tip off
and he was met by airport security as
soon as he came through
when you say he was returning to Moscow
was he coming
to Russia back from the United States
yes he was coming back from the United
States from Oakmont he lives in Oakmont
Pennsylvania that's the last time you
saw him yes his bro he had a 60th
birthday party uh on July 28th and on
what was it August 14th he was he was
detained
um I think that he was probably fed some
information that he desperately wanted
to believe because after three failed
back surgeries hip surgery shoulder
surgery his chronic pain levels are a
24-hour a day job
we produced um a stack of medical
records probably three inches thick but
they didn't care and he was convicted in
June of this year of drug trafficking
when your brother was sentenced
he was sent to where in Russia
well I don't think they knew where to
send them to be honest with you he can't
um he can't work I mean I think that
that would it would probably kill him
they have sent him to not where the
others went they sent him to north of
Moscow to uh the town of rybinsk they
are not allowing him to work which is
interesting because it must be pretty
obvious to them that they can't is this
a penal colony as they call it it is a
penal colony and he's allowed to use the
phone now he's allowed to to receive one
package every three months and here's an
interesting story
he received a package the other day that
was full of rotten fruit my my brother
is a real uh real fruititarian okay but
it was filled with rotten fruit and he
was panic-stricken because this was his
one package for three months so he took
it to the main office and they allowed
him to refuse the package and it was as
if like the greatest most extraordinary
kindness was given he was so touched
that they allowed him to refuse the
package who sent him the fruit uh a
friend of his in Moscow it was chasing
you know he was in transition for four
or five weeks
um we had no track of him no one heard
from him there was never there was not a
way to get any letters to him
so
um I guess this package was just
floating around out there but it finally
made its way to rybinsk and it was uh it
had all gone bad so he now will be able
to get a package hopefully he'll be able
to he'll be able to get a package now
are you planning to send one
uh we have contacts in Russia that that
handle some of this stuff for us okay
what has he told you I assume you have
spoken to him on the phone now that he
can talk yeah what does he tell you
well the sad thing is is he really can't
tell us much of anything he did say that
he was watching a bunch of older men
having a snowball fight so I'm sure that
that's the kind of thing that um the the
authorities would love him to tell
people sounds like fun sounds like fun
he's having fun uh yeah
it's um he you know it's a one-way
conversation for the most part he you
know we're we're telling him what we're
doing which is also like you can't I
don't I don't wanna I don't really want
to tell him that I've gone out skiing or
that I you know we had people over for a
dinner party so it makes it very
difficult yeah to have a conversation
with him
um
and he's got someone listening on the
other end so he can't talk about
anything in real emotion or or real
information
right and how long can you speak to him
for 10-minute segments okay
and it depends on if someone else is
waiting in line for the phone
all right and does he I mean again I was
going to ask you does he say the food's
good but he's good what's he gonna say
the food's terrible the conditions are
terrible he's not going to say that he
said he said about the food that it's um
being fed
primarily he's a big fed yeah cabbage
and potatoes cabbage and potatoes
yeah
does he know that Brittany Greiner came
home yes he does
what did he say
he said I'm trying to stay
hopeful I mean he has a 14-year sentence
to serve yeah he said he had his 60th
birthday
has he told you anything that he fears
he's going to be there forever
of course
of course
he's afraid of dying there
my mother's afraid he's going to die
there we're all afraid of that
I can't even imagine how hard this must
be
yeah it's it's it's
bad
it's it's certainly
um
makes a lot of other problems pale in
comparison
what is next for you what will you do
next
we are going to doggedly pursue the
state department until they give him
the wrongful detainment classification
and after that
I don't know
I assume you'll hope that there's
another prisoner exchange yeah we we
surely do maybe you know maybe they'll
bring him home with Paul Whalen
well we certainly wish for better news
for your family and that you can welcome
Mark home soon
Ann Fogle sister of Mark Fogle who
continues to be in prison in Russia
thank you very much for joining us
thanks for having me and giving me this
time
[Music]
and in other news I'm Gianna jalosi
Wildlife officials in Los Angeles nabbed
the city's most famous mountain lion
accused of murdering a dog in the
Hollywood Hills the Cougar's name is P22
he made a name for himself by roaming
freeways making a sprawling Urban Park
his home and terrorizing local pets Los
Angeles Wildlife officials tranquilized
the big cat this week hoping to get a
closer look at him they say P22 is a
remarkably old cat for the wild an
estimated 12 years old and his recent
killing of that leash dog may be a sign
of distress there were also reports he
was hit by a car Wildlife officials say
most mountain lions live to be about 10
years old in the wild but having said
what might happen to P22 after his
examination p-22 usually hunts deer and
coyotes but in November the National
Park Service confirmed the cougar
attacked and killed a Chihuahua mix that
was being walked on the narrow streets
of the Hollywood Hills he's also
suspected of attacking another Chihuahua
in the silver lake neighborhood this
month p-22 was the face of a campaign to
to build a wildlife crossing over a Los
Angeles area freeway to give big cats
coyotes deer and other Wildlife a safe
path into the nearby Santa Monica
Mountains JP Rose policy director for
the center for biological diversity said
p-22's distress in his old age quote
underscores the need to proactively
protect mountain lions and other
Wildlife by reconnecting the landscape
the bridge which will stretch 200 feet
over U.S 101 broke ground this year and
is expected to be completed by early
2025. for the Fox News rundown I'm
Gianna jalosi
foreign
[Music]
Fox News Radio On Demand on the Fox News
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite Fox News talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
Fox News Radio newscasts On Demand Fox
News Radio and the Fox News app
downloaded today Braden review the Fox
News rundown on Apple podcasts or
wherever you listen it's time for your
Fox News commentary
what's on your mind sometimes life just
isn't fair Gary razor age 83 was laid to
rest last week in Durham North Carolina
Services were held at the Clemens
Funeral Home on Broad Street their motto
is service not measured by gold but by
the Golden Rule such a statement and
sentiment could be said of Gary razor
who passed away on November 30th from
injuries sustained from a senseless
attack inside a Home Depot store a
nearby Hillsboro in North Carolina
it all started back on October 18th when
Gary who was employed by the Home
Improvement giant approached a hooded
man shoplifting three Ryobi pressure
washers the thief didn't even break
stride forcefully shoving the clerk to
the ground causing him to bang his head
on the concrete floor upon impact Mr
razor made a valiant recovery effort but
the extent of his injuries and age were
just too much to overcome
known as Mr Gary inside the store the
Ohio native and army veteran was the
ideal go-to guy for home Fixit advice
although he sold insurance after serving
his country in the military Gary spent
the rest of his years in the
construction business he managed a
condominium complex and was a longtime
owner of a fencing company
you know what happened to Gary is
Fallout from a culture that's lost its
Mooring it's what happens when you
disrespect life it's what happens when
families fall apart and when values are
discarded
so say a prayer for Gary's wife Yvonne
and the whole razor family and all those
who have lost loved ones from violent
crime this year their grief is heavy
unimaginable really
you know Gary lived a bold and
courageous life he served his country
his family and his neighbors and he
didn't stop serving until the end
Gary raiser's life ended tragically but
the way he lived his life should still
be an inspiration to us all
I'm Paw Patrol
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown now and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad free on
FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple podcasts
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
listen to the all-new Brett Bear podcast
featuring Common Ground in-depth talks
with lawmakers from opposite sides of
the aisle along with all your bear
favorites like his All-Star panel and
much more available now at
foxnewspodcasts.com or wherever you get
your podcasts